and one of the main headliners we can
expect this weekend country superstar
garth brooks he is making his allegiant
stadium debut tomorrow night
the singer has a long history right here
in vegas sasha loftus sat down with the
legend today he spoke
about his return to the stage and also
shared why he's so excited to be back in
the valley
we got the chance to sit down with garth
brooks here at allegion stadium as he
gets ready for his big show
this weekend it's one of many kicking
off all across
las vegas the goal is for these people
to leave the stadium loving each other
more
garth was all smiles says he spoke about
his return to the stage here in las
vegas
he said it's more important than ever
for his band and crew to get back to
work
after a pandemic related pause if i
could pick the best show i ever want to
have
it's this one that's going to kick off
the remainder of the stadium shows
brooks has a long history here in the
valley performing at the desert inn
thomas and mack the win t-mobile arena
and now
allegion stadium he told me this city
and this community
means a lot to him biggest thing about
vegas and everybody talks about the
lights and
all that stuff the greatest thing about
vegas are the people they just are
because it's these people that are at
the root of everything so let's go all
the way back to the desert inn let's go
all the way back to thomas mack
those people are just
just common sense people and that's what
makes you feel at home masks are
required at allegiant if you're not
vaccinated and garth encouraged everyone
to stay
safe and respect anyone in attendance
whether they're wearing a face covering
or not
now as i mentioned a lot of big events
happening this weekend
all over the valley if you'd like a list
of things you can check out
we have that on our website
eightnewsnow.com
reporting from allegion stadium sasha
loftis 8 news now
all right so keep this in mind as you
take a look at this legend here if
you're going to be going to the concert
or driving anywhere near alleged stadium
tomorrow night
give yourself extra time there are so
many things happening it's going to be
packed this weekend on the strip
so a hacienda is going to be closed to
all vehicle traffic
so it can turn into an actual pedestrian
bridge
a dean martin will also only be open
southbound
oquindo westbound only and you can only
go north on polaris from russell
now i know that's a lot so if you didn't
catch all of it don't worry we're going
to have it for you also online at
8newsnow.com